[Music]
when the very first balloon was launched
that could carry people it was in Paris
in the late 1700s and it was Montgolfier
the brothers they had hydrogen balloons
and hot-air balloons and it was the
cutting edge of science it was the
cutting edge of technology we just
learned how to capture a gas like
hydrogen that would be lighter than air
if you could make a balloon and the
first balloon rose and Ben Franklin was
there and it was huge and magnificent
all of those scientists and it rose but
it got out of control and it went and
landed out in the countryside 15 miles
away from Paris and the peasants there
attacked it with pitchforks because they
thought it was an alien coming from
space the schism between learn an
understanding and scientific pursuits
and the common perception of what was
normal was that close just 15 miles away
there was an enormous gap between what
we knew and what we were doing and what
a lot of folks knew yet or what did what
had become part of common knowledge so
there's nothing new about about the
speed with which we're inventing things
and the ability for people to understand
what's going on there's there's a recent
populace sort of wave of of anti science
and as if that's something new it's
mostly because social media has given
everybody what appears to be an equal
voice on the corner of Hyde Park in
London there's speaker's corner and that
used to be the Internet where you could
go stand there and yell any stupid thing
you wanted and if people wanted to
gather round and listen that was their
choice but if you if you weren't
interested in whatever that person was
spouting then you didn't need to listen
but now internet is sort of turned
everything into the speaker's corner so
you really have to just decide what what
are you gonna listen to and what aren't
you and if someone decides to put
forward some stupid idea that is
patently false like if somebody says the
sky is orange you can have an argument
about it if you want but but it's it's
obviously not true so there's really no
point in even engaging in conversation
or if somebody says the world is flat
it's patently untrue so there's no point
in engaging in conversation because all
you're doing is is giving that person
credibility for something that we've
known for thousands of years to not be
truth so so I just I don't even worry
about it the world is full of
fascinating interesting new discoveries
and and we're pushing the very
boundaries of what we know Stephen
Hawking who just recently died the work
that he did and trying to understand how
the universe works
the original thinking there there's so
many brilliant motivated people around
that why would you engage with someone
who is being deliberately ignorant I
don't mind people that just don't know
that then they're just in the process of
learning but if someone has chosen to
take the facts and be deliberately
stupid about them then I think they've
discounted themself from rational
conversation so I don't bother if you
wrestle with a pig the best you can be
is a pig wrestler so I want to do better
than that so just because somebody says
something no matter how big their
megaphone is doesn't mean that they
deserve conversation just use your own
brain that's why we each have one and
choose who you're gonna disregard
[Music]
you